This entire process is called U-Substitution. It's when we can take an equation
an we make a substitution, to turn it in to our quadratic equation. Here we've
replaced the repeated expression x squared, with the variable u. We created
this so we could perform the substitution. Now we could have made any
assignment for x squared. We didn't have to use the variable u. We could call
this t substitution and use t or w substitution and use w. It doesn't matter
what variable you use here you just want to make sure you use the same one
throughout your problem solving. Keep in mind that we performed this
substitution so we could have a factorable quadratic. We factor this expression
to solve for the values of u. Keep in mind that these values are not our final
answer. We need to find the original values of the original variable, which was
x. So we take our answers, u equals 9, and u equals 4, and we replace u with
the original variable that we substituted, x squared. We solved for the
original variable which is x, which gave us our four solutions. Now if you're
not convinced that each of these is a solution, try checking them in the
original equation. You'll find that all four of them check.